[Music]
he was a hero to me live with Bruce
Wayne is gonna change your life I
admired him at first the police they
believe it may not have been an accident
but I had to walk away I was becoming
too much like him
Tigers have always been my favorite ever
since I was a kid haha you have to be
naked so can't believe you traded in the
force for a mini man I really like to be
back no my mom says there's no such
thing as monsters I think she's wrong
when I feel that darkness come out it
feels good
there's a power inside of me something I
don't understand
shall we begin sometimes it comes out
total darkness where did you see you
were from again
I didn't
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie happy trailer
week we got so much footage to break
down this obviously dealing with the
Titans origins in their relative powers
there's a new round of that giveaway for
the DC streaming service all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video I'll do that in
all my Titans like DC streaming service
videos so no worries within the first
couple of episodes you actually do get
Robyn's backstory he's the first big
person that they explained then they do
Raven then they move through the other
characters you see him here at his
parents grave this is just meant to
mirror Batman visiting his parents grave
because their origin stories are similar
my parents were murdered
you get Bruce Wayne you get Wayne Manor
Alfred you get all that stuff with him
as a kid in his first couple of days at
the Wayne mansion when he's sitting here
with the police and they're like we
believe that it might not have been an
accident that have killed your parents
he sees this letter from Bruce Wayne
somebody wants to adopt you and because
his parents have just died he could care
less who Bruce Wayne is like all he
knows is that his family is gone but
what they do through the first couple of
episodes is sort of give you a little
bit more of his time with Batman
so like first you get this with the
letter he wants to adopt you after the
accident then you move through the slow
progression of him being a bit of a
rebel then Bruce finally telling him
there's another way let me teach you how
to channel your anger Geoff Johns has
already said that they have a lot of
really awesome scenes in the Batcave I
imagine that's both flashbacks and maybe
in present day tube because they keep
referring to Batman in present-day
through the series too but every time
you hear Robin talk about him he refers
to him as Bruce like within his cell
phone like he's scanning through phone
numbers he has Alfred his name is in
there as Bruce so if he wanted to call
Batman he would be calling Bruce Wayne
technically I've already done a video
about that Jason Todd trailer so I'll
link that at the end of this but
obviously that comes much later in the
series remember it's 12 episodes so a
lot of this backstory stuff you get
within the first couple but then once
you do Robins origin then you sort of
deal with the new Robin and I wouldn't
be surprised in a future season
obviously we've been talking about Red
Hood if we also do the Tim Drake Robin
but that might take a little bit longer
because first you have to introduce the
idea of Jason Todd then you have to kill
him off you have to do death in the
family then after a hot minute you could
do Tim Drake then a little while after
that you can
do red hood because they're doing to
Robin's already pretty safe bet that
they could do the third Robin as well
but probably one of the other bigger
things about this is that you get to see
Beast Boy transform into a lion now he
does that a couple times in this series
at this clip of him inside this Best Buy
lookin store here that's from the first
episode it's just a reference to beast
boy's first appearance in the comics in
Doom Patrol number 99 so they come back
to their lair and they find that it's
been trashed and they learned that it's
Beast Boy he transforms into a bunch of
different animals like when he says he's
always transformed into Tigers because
that's his favorite animal there's just
a reference to his first appearance you
see him take down the criminal while
he's in Tiger form so this is kind of
what he's gonna look like it's a little
more polished in the actual series but
then you see the corresponding shot with
everybody else activating their powers
like Raven is in full-on dark mode nice
joke about him being really pissed off
about the minivan early in the season
Robin is driving one of Bruce Wayne's
classic air-cooled Porsches so if you're
really big fan of Porsches he drives a
really badass one for the first part of
the series but once they all come
together obviously they need to travel
together so that's probably where the
minivan comes in he does sort of lighten
the mood just a little bit because Robin
is pretty serious when the series picks
up Starfire is also kind of hardcore and
Raven obviously you know all about
Ravens personality so Beast Boy is there
to balance the tone just a little bit I
would totally love to meet Batman this
is actually from a different scene it's
like the Batman f-bomb that Robin
dropped in that first big trailer so
they kind of did the same thing with
this the actual scene is a little bit
different with the way that dialogue
plays out
speaking of Batman though I know there's
been rumors about his supposed costume I
haven't seen every single episode of
Titans yet so I can't tell you
definitively and I don't think I'd even
be allowed to whether or not Batman
actually shows up in a back costume but
it kind of seems like he does but the
whole thing is is that you get a little
bit more Bruce Wayne in every single
episode so like you just see him in the
background in shots in the early
episodes then you get a much bigger
frontal shot of him so it just seems
like we get more and more Bruce Wayne
Batman as we get to the end of the
season the part of the clip that shows
you Ravens powers also doesn't quite do
that full justice she can actually enter
people's mouths
smoke monster mode so she can actually
do quite a bit more than this but she
still doesn't totally understand her
powers and they're gonna get more and
more powerful towards the end of the
season season one is largely dedicated
to Robin and ravens arcs so Ravens
slowly learning about her powers growing
more powerful in Robins slowly becoming
Nightwing but if you've ever seen any of
the cartoons read any of the comics you
kind of know what's going on with her
character she's slowly learning who her
father is
Trigon what happened to her real mother
who was taken by the Church of blood and
how he wants to use her as a vessel to
enter our universe but he needs to be
invited by her so every time Raven gives
herself over to the darkness within her
she sort of puts herself at risk for
letting her father into this world so
the whole idea with her is that she
needs to learn to control the darkness
not necessarily ignore it like she can't
ignore who she is the whole deal with
Starfire is that she doesn't exactly
know who she is because of some amnesiac
event that happened we don't know a lot
about that when the series begins so I'm
assuming that they'll explain it in the
later episodes but the whole idea is
that she's supposed to be one of the
most Opie members of the team but
because she doesn't remember who she is
she doesn't know how to use her powers
so even though she can fly she can shoot
energy beams most of the time when you
see her using her powers
she's just roasting people alive and
blasting holes and walls like this this
bunker here where they're in is actually
her old lair like she finds this and
she's like why was i searching for
something what was i searching for so
she's also been on the hunt for Raven
separately from what Robin finds out so
they all sort of come to this mystery
about where Raven comes from in this
whole prophecy from the Church of blood
and Trigon in separate ways and it's
their desire to take care of Raven who's
like this helpless seeming little girl
even though she's not that helpless this
sort of inspires them to become a team
like they're not superhot on each other
when they first meet but they all care
about what happens to Raven so they're
like okay we'll figure this out and then
eventually they grow closer towards the
end of the season I imagined and as far
as costume changes go yes there is a
rumor that they all get their new
costumes in the final episode but I
haven't seen it yet so that's still a
rumor I'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery review of the premiere next
week that will post on when
day so look out for that I'll remind
people when we get a little bit closer
the actual episodes will be available to
watch on the DC streaming service
starting every Friday on the 12th and
it'll be a weekly show just like the
other DC TV shows so what'll happen is
is there was a whole bunch other footage
that dropped I'll do a daredevil season
3 trailer next that should be up in the
next couple of hours and I'll name a
giveaway winner for this when I post new
DC we just learned a whole bunch of
stuff about the flash arrow three-way
crossover they're doing Elseworlds
we have the monitor confirming crisis on
Infinite Earths in a future season
crossover click here for that Jason Todd
trailer and click here for that brand
new venom trailer thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight